The train is coming.
The train is coming and so am I.
I have my... I'm using my special camera today.
I'm using my special GoPro.
It's getting the up close and fancy sights.
And my reaction to the train.
Starrace, happy birthday!
Instead of a song, I'm gonna get a birthday rap.
I was gonna say, I'm holding off on songs for a minute.
Because of my voice.
But I can give you a rap.
Happy, happy birthday.
It's your birthday today.
Starrace, you're one year older and then you will have cake.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
The train is coming and so have I.
I laughed last because you came to die.
Not the train!
You will have cake.
Yeah!
You will have cake!
Did I get a haircut?
I got a hair long.
That's what Mint looks like without the filter.
Starrace, you would still love me even if I were a 360 cam Vtuber, right?
Isn't that the camera that Francis uses?
This song is such a bop.
Anyway guys, welcome to Japan Train Models.
Which I think in the Japanese title is...
Densha Tetsudo?
Or Marugoto!
Marugoto!
Marugoto Tetsudo.
Foreigners like to manipulate images like this.
Except sometimes I do it myself.
Every aspect ratio.
This is me waiting for the train.
Don't you want to see my reaction?
When the train comes?
I'm getting that British train spotter vibes.
I feel like I'm melting.
I feel like I've become... You know how people say cats are liquid?
That's how I feel.
Congrats on 350k?
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
This is the 350k stream.
I only know a little bit about this game.
I just wanted to hang out and play with some trains.
It's so good!
I'm turning 29 today.
I'm still young, right?
Of course!
You need to rest your voice, but could you tell Chat that you're proud of us?
Chat...
Chat, I'm proud of you.
I'm proud of you, Chat.
I'm proud of you.
You're doing the thing.
And I'm proud of you for it.
Oh my god, I can make myself... Why is my cheek so...
I
have like a butt chin.
Oh
my...
Hold on, hold on.
Let me move over.
There we go.
I look like a hamster.
Now it looks like I have something stuck in my throat.
Potion seller.
No, I'm the guy that...
I'm the guy that watches the trains.
I'm the guy.
I'm the guy, you know?
The guy that does the train thing.
Show me your strongest potion.
No!
Masoken, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday.
Yeah, so this is probably gonna be not even the very long stream.
We'll see.
I might get into it, because there is like a creator part where you can like create your own train lines and stuff.
And I kinda just wanna take nice pictures and learn about trains, so I hope that's okay.
This is not like a... This is my own selfish kind of stream.
Thanks, Kaleidoscope Minky.
I
think pretty sure though this is a mobile game.
Oh my god.
Wow, look at it go!
Oh, the sound.
Oh wow, there's no like... Oh gosh, anybody who passes by is gonna die.
Dang, it's zooming.
The cherry blossoms!
Oh my gosh, that's such a nice... Oh my god.
Such a nice photo.
Okay, we're gonna get lots of good pictures.
So we have like... Look, we have encyclopedia where it tells you all about different trains.
Finish.
Wait, am I... Should I be playing this on controller?
Look, it tells you all about... Oh my gosh.
Wait, is this like the one with the green seats?
I've never sat in a green seat one because it costs extra.
What is this?
Okay, hold on.
On the 3D view... Oh my god, we can go inside!
Try observing the interior from the camera angle inside the vehicle.
Use the R... Okay, hold on.
Let me get my controller.
R stick to change the angle.
Use the R button.
You never know what new discoveries you might make.
Wait, I can go in?
Oh, my bad.
Scroll up.
Scroll down.
Oh, it's talking about this.
Wait, how do I... How do I like...
Oh, there we go.
Camera move.
Okay, zoom out a little bit.
How do I go inside?
Maybe if I zoom in enough.
Enhance.
Take it.
Oh, train interior!
Oh my gosh.
This must be the green seats, no?
Wait.
Next camera.
There's the... There's the... Upstairs.
Oh my gosh, look how detailed this is.
Yes!
Green car ticket fair!
I've never been on this one because like as you can see, it costs more.
Like you have to get a separate ticket.
You can't just use your Suica or anything like that.
And then you can see...
If you go... If you go below 50 kilometers on weekdays, it's 1040 yen.
And on weekends and holidays, it's 840 yen.
Oh, that's kind of nice.
It's cheaper on weekends and holidays?
I feel like that's always the opposite, no?
You can tap Suica, but it's when you take the seat.
Okay, I see I've never done it before.
Thank you.
And then if you go over 51 kilometers, it's a little more pricey.
What's the... I can't read the stuff on this side though.
Oh.
We enhanced too far.
I can't... I don't know.
I can't read it.
I don't think the train says that.
Please hold...
Please hold the handrail.
They got the harder one, security camera in operation.
That one I feel like is...
Is more difficult.
Hold my hand.
Don't do that.
Oh look, there's... Oh, the Mana Modo.
Oh yeah, these are all... Oh my gosh, these are all like legitimate signs that you see everywhere.
Instead of... Instead of like vibrate...
For phones, they call it Manor Mode.
Or not... Or like a silent mode, that's what I mean.
They call it... They call it Manor Mode.
Mana... Mana Modo.
Mana Modo.
That's why I'm like Manor Mode.
Watch for sudden stops.
I've never had a train stop suddenly before.
But I have been stuck on a train...
During a... What's the word?
During a earthquake.
Oh look at the tiny stabs.
Watch your step everybody.
Watch your step.
Please hold the handrail, okay?
Congrats on 315K, thank you!
My new model.
Wow, these seats look so comfy, no?
Wow, even the print on them.
Just... It's like not Leopard.
And they got the little tray tables.
It's like very much like a plane.
Green car.
What's next?
Oh, upstairs.
Oh these... Wow.
The colors are different.
Blue... Jaguar...
Leopard.
The handle is so strange.
Oh, this one has the little drink holder too.
It feels like we're... It feels like we're on the train, you guys.
Really feels like it.
Wait, I wanna go... Wait, where are we?
Is this a restroom?
Yup.
That's a wall.
I wanna get to the front, you know?
Wait, I think it's now repeating.
No, I wanted to see the front of the train!
Hold on.
Let's see.
Oh wait, maybe because...
It's only... Oh okay, this is just the passenger...
Car.
What does this do?
Oh, just kidding.
I think you need to switch cars.
I think so too.
Let's see, hold on.
Oh my gosh!
First year in service, 2008.
Does that mean he'll accept us even when we're freaky?
I don't know what this is in context to, but...
Yeah.
120 kilometers per hour.
These things are zooming.
These little trains.
Wait, what was the other one?
When was this in service from?
2008.
What's like the oldest one we've got here?
2008...2008...2008...2008...
2008...2008...
I think I've...Did I reset?
Actually, okay, I think I reset.
Yeah.
So there's only a few we got here.
Everything 2008.
Inside...
Oh no, these ones suck.
Wait, actually...
Oh, maybe...I don't think actually any of the JR...
The JR East...
I don't think any of these ones have the...
So some of them have like TV screens and some of them are just like the...
Like the scrolling text.
But this one looks like a TV screen.
Oh my gosh, all of these...All of these...
Are like the same exact signs you see...Oh my god!
It's the same exact signs!
I've never seen this before though.
Interesting.
Oh, Lumi!
Thank you for the raid!
Hi guys, we're looking at trains.
We built a deck.
Did you?
Is this the very model of a modern major train?
Yes, actually.
It's like the...
It's a door cock.
Yeah, and then, you know...
It might be like...
Oh, sometimes there's like no seats here for like strollers and all that.
Wheelchairs.
Emergency door opening.
What do you mean I'm extra freaky today?
I literally just read it.
That's what it says.
Door cock.
What?
But yeah, you know, sometimes you'll just be like minding your own business.
And then all the way right there, usually they are in the seats on the edge.
Because no one wants to be by them.
There'll just be some guy shitting and pissing and throwing up all over himself.
That Shibuya meltdown.
Wow, it makes it look so big.
Through my camera.
Wow.
It's just how it is.
Classic site.
Yeah, very classic.
Very classic!
What is this one?
Hold on.
Oh, okay, it's the same thing.
Just kidding.
Which one is your favorite?
Hold on.
Oh, there's the... there, there, there.
Hold on, hold on.
Do I have to like unlock more or...
Where am I?
I can't move!
Wait!
Oh my god, wait, wait!
Wait, wait!
Let me in!
Okay.
I wanna see!
I wanna see the controls!
I wanna be in the driver's seat!
I wanna be!
See, like, this screen looks really small...
To be...
To be a TV screen.
No, it looks thin.
Don't let her in.
Let me in.
I don't go on these ones very often.
The ones with these seats...
What?
What line is this on?
What line do you find these?
Gotta play Densha de GO!
I wanna play!
I wanna play Densha de GO.
What the heck?
What is over here?
This is so strange.
Tokaido line?
I think they are like this from Tokyo to Fuji-Q.
Really?
I've always taken the bus to Fuji-Q.
Do you not take a Shinkansen?
I guess that would be faster.
Shonan Shinjuku as well.
I can't see anything!
This is the worst camera angle ever!
I always like to wave at the guys when I look out the window though.
Shonan Shinjuku.
I want to see inside.
Maybe they are like, we can't show you.
It will give away our secrets.
How many trains for Fuji-Q?
It's like two expresses a day or something.
Oh, really?
There is no Shinkansen to Fuji-Q though.
No, you can take...
Well, it's not like two Fuji-Q trains.
But it's to the area.
Taking the bus to Fuji-Q.
YouTubers.
The YouTubers will break in.
No!
I wonder if you can see...
Oh, look at that.
Hold on.
These ones don't seem to have like the air conditioning under the...
In the winter time, the seats, they will have like a heat underneath.
And they make your legs toasty.
Uh-oh, is YouTube going down?
Lightbulb, Headed Minto, share your wisdom.
If you gotta go, then you should go.
It's fine now?
These like little privacy seats are so funny.
But you have so much less sitting room.
It kinda sucks.
Or maybe it's the same.
But I would feel awkward sitting and staring at someone like that.
I don't know how I would feel about that.
I already feel bad because if I'm sitting and like looking out the window...
But someone is across from me, they already think I'm looking at them.
Which one haven't we looked at?
We looked at this one.
E233.
It literally says Shonan Shinjuku Line.
You guys are so smart.
And Ueno Tokyo Line, etc.
Ah!
3000 series.
232.
Kuha?
Moha?
What's it say up there?
It's the local...
Takasaki desu.
It's inverted controls.
This is...
Not the one we were just in.
But we were in this one before.
I wish they told us a little bit more about the cars.
You can see everything underneath too.
All the bits and parts.
Company secrets.
The doors on the right side will open.
They're trains.
You know what I mean.
The cars.
This is the car.
The train car.
Yeah, this is a car stream actually.
Hi, Vet.
Lumi4Face is very nice.
Thank you, your time.
Thank you, your super chat.
I wanna see, I wanna learn all the bits and pieces.
I've never seen this either.
I've never seen these buttons.
Oh gosh, it won't let me zoom up anymore.
But, there we go.
Ah, yes.
I guess, oh, it's just opening the door.
I've never seen these buttons before.
Push it.
They light up so nice, right?
I wonder where I could go to take this.
Is this also to Takasaki?
Yup.
I wonder where I could go.
I guess to Takasaki.
What is in Takasaki?
Let's see.
I'm gonna Google.
What is in Takasaki?
Japan, Takasaki.
The stream is truly built for me and my train's special interest.
Thank you, Vet.
Of course.
Also, Hero Juggler, I'm sorry I missed you.
Megamind, Minto defeats Chilly Minto.
And Rockin' and Gaming, thank you!
Oh, wait, Joshua.
StreamLive now forces my email, so I feel like I should note that.
Have you ever heard of Densha de GO?
I have!
Actually, my friend has a Densha de GO cab, so...
Hometown of Daruma Doll?
No way.
It's in Gunma.
Wait, maybe I'm looking up the wrong Takasaki.
It's telling...
Oh, wait, no, just kidding.
What is Takasaki, Japan, known for?
Close to Tokyo and Nagano, the city of Takasaki is best known for two things.
Steam, locomotives, and Daruma Dolls.
Oh my gosh, we can actually choo-choo.
We can actually chugga-chugga-choo-choo.
Show us the cab.
It's not mine, it's my friend's.
You guys, how many chuggas do you do?
I do 8 chuggas.
I saw some people in the pre-chat, they were like, I do 6 chuggas.
I do...
I do 15...
Or...
I do 8.
Chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-choo-choo.
I think that just feels...
The best amount.
Chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-choo-choo.
Why Minto Concave?
This is my special camera.
I try to be inconsistent.
4 feels right, I feel like that's too small.
No, you gotta have the build-up.
Chugga-chugga-chugga-chugga-choo-choo.
I've been a fan and a follower since the good old Doom days.
Oh my gosh, Francisco, thank you.
I actually got sad last year...
Because I thought I'll never hear you sing happy birthday which is today!
But now, here we are.
We're alive kind of, I'm making full.
Well...
Francisco, I wasn't going to be singing birthday songs for a bit...
Because my throat was kind of messed up.
But since you've been waiting for so long...
Since Doom...
I will sing.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Francisco.
Happy birthday!
Depends on the context.
Sometimes it's a small chugga.
Sometimes it's long, but like they say, length is not what's important.
I think it is.
In this context?
In what context would you not want a good chugga buildup?
I should be finishing packing for Japan.
But instead I'm watching a comfy stream about trains that I'll be riding later.
Oh my gosh, wait.
You're gonna literally be like...
You're gonna... Wait, how do I get inside?
Wait, let me in.
How do I get inside again?
Why is it not letting me inside?
Hold on.
Oh, there's more!
Wait, we were just at this one!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I pressed the back button.
My bad.
Wait, wait, wait.
I don't want to do puzzle mode yet.
Wait, back, back, back.
Back, back, back.
Encyclopedia.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, I think this... Yes!
I was gonna say this is the one that I'm most used to.
I'm so... Oh my gosh!
This face is iconic.
Oh my god!
It's the Yamanote-sen!
When?
It's iconic.
Since 2016.
Oh.
Hello, Butaro.
Are you tired of hearing me talk?
My cats are in here.
Both of them, they were sleeping together.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
This is how they do the announcements and...
Oh my gosh, I want to know everything!
I want to play Densha de GO!
I want to play!
Oh, I wish I could see outside!
Look, this one is red.
The other one was yellow.
I wonder if it gets... I read...
I wonder how stressful to comforting this job is, you know?
I love the creeper seats.
I love the creeper seats!
Oh my gosh, this is like so...
See?
This is what I meant by the screens and everything.
Yes!
These are the TV screens.
That's just a Minecraft creeper.
Oh my gosh, you can even see the butt imprint.
This is too realistic.
This is too realistic, I fear.
All those salarymen that have sat here...
Priority seat.
I'm pretty sure these all...
Wait, can I go inside?
Let me in, please.
I'm gonna just be a creeper from outdoors.
Yamagote.
I don't know, I...
Personally...
I mean, I know that Yamagote is so convenient because it goes to so many places.
Also, it just gets so crowded.
Us?
Wait, where did that comment go?
Wait, hold on.
Oh.
Basically means unmotored trailer car.
Ah, I see, I see.
So then...
So then the kuha...
Would be if it's motored?
But then what's a moha?
Kuha means cat.
So you guys are teaching me more about this than the game.
Hold on, let me let my cat out.
Moha means mode.
That makes sense.
Wait, no, wait, oh.
Oh, wait, hold on.
This...
Then you can do funny stuff like a kumoha is a motored cat.
Why won't it let me inside?
Priority seating.
This is the one we went in before though.
Oh, I guess we can't go in this one.
Maybe they're just like it's the same exactly.
Can't say cause clash.
But dang, that's a big forehead.
Oh my gosh, wait, what if I do this?
It becomes a little concave.
Wait, hold on, now I wanna see.
So salo, I'm guessing is like the double decker ones then.
And the moha.
And you can see up here.
And then...
There's a translation there, it's supposed to be salo.
Oh my gosh.
Nasa Nyeru knows so much.
I'm learning so much, thank you.
This is so awesome.
So it's salo instead.
Well, I guess...
Salo, salo.
Trailer green car.
Okay, okay.
Maybe it's short for saloon.
I'm gonna look at that.
Hold on.
We're learning about trains today, everybody.
Wait, 3000 series, here we go.
I see it.
That's cool.
Cool ha moha moha moha.
Oh, it's like showing me.
Wait, like the formation.
So it would be like kuha moha moha moha moha.
Salo, salo.
Moha moha kuha.
But wait, I wanna see what salo stands for.
I don't like it.
Row
is green car, ha is normal car.
I guess in this game, lol.
Lol.
Lol lol lol.
Tributing to the Abydos Trans Desert Railway.
Thank you.
Oh, it even says like what lines it does.
I'm on Wikipedia.
Sorry, hold on.
Now I can't stop reading.
Okay, I need to stop reading.
Hold on.
We still have...
This series too.
You look a little different today.
Did you change your hair?
I wonder how it looks with twin tails.
Round.
Why does it look even more round like this?
Why does it look even more round?
Odoriko.
Why is it so bright in my eyes?
Oh, golly.
It's so stinking bright.
Oh my gosh.
Stop.
It's so cute.
I look like I belong in here.
Why is this so cute?
Kuha.
It even says Kuha here.
Oh my gosh.
It's so cute.
It's a mint color.
Not gonna lie, at first I thought that was like a...
Like a place to brew tea or coffee.
You got the little phone and then the little spinning...
Wait, let's see.
In here.
A little privacy before you go into the...
Main car.
Okay, so these are...
You don't... You can just sit wherever.
So, car...
Trains sometimes like this have assigned seating, but then there's also like...
It's like free seating, but it's also like first come, first serve.
You know, overtime is expected when there's a built-in espresso machine.
Yeah.
You should totally play Densha Dego.
I want to!
Wait, hold on.
185 series.
That can rock a rabbit!
Congrats on the 350K and one year reopening membership.
It's also my birthday!
Last year, my superchat got lost in a sea of new bamboos.
No need to strain your voice doing a slam poetry style MGSB day.
You can just tell me I'm...
Pretty old.
No, no!
Rock for rabbit!
I will sing you a happy birthday.
You waited since last year.
I'm sorry that I got lost.
I'm sorry!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, rock for rabbit.
Happy birthday, you're pretty old.
Sorry that I'm doing it in this song.
In this look.
Why is it so bright?
So then this one's also a green car.
Oh yeah, there's a symbol.
Oh my gosh, it's so bright.
Everything is like reflecting like crazy.
That's a sasato.
I learned.
I'm learned.
I took what I learned and I'm applying it.
Moha!
So I'm just confirming... I know this is like...
This isn't like the motor part of the moha, is it?
Because I know it's like the electricity blah blah.
I actually don't know.
I know like...
My head is melting.
Yeah, a little bit.
Sometimes when you're going about your day, do you get the DuckTales theme song popping in your head?
Sometimes.
It's called a pentagraph.
Oh, it touches the wire.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold on, I'm gonna look it up.
On the train.
Transport.
Here we go.
Apparatus mounted onto the roof of an electric train, tram, or trolleybuses to collect power through contact with an overhead line.
Oh...
The term stems from the resemblance of some styles to the mechanical pentagraphs used for...
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
I see it!
That's cra... Oh my gosh!
Wait...
I saw... This is actually like kind of a trend kind of right now is...
Using like a pentagraph to... Well, it's not exactly a pentagraph.
It's a little different, but something similar to like...
Scratch images into graphite and... Or not... What was it?
It wasn't graphite.
It was granite.
But I saw it!
I saw like people trying to do it.
And like when you then...
When you then...
When you like move the...
It's not glass.
It was something.
Yeah, you like make a hologram basically.
It's really cool, actually.
I got an achievement!
Oh, for playing more than one hour!
What?
Wait... What are the achievements?
There's 13 achievements in this game.
Marutetsu Mini... Oh, I got the fan achievement.
Only 25% of players have this achievement.
Okay.
We will play the game.
I'm just so fascinated with like the models.
Sorry.
There's a game?
A little bit.
Yeah, actually.
Shall we go check it out?
Oh, wait.
Back.
So we did the 185 series.
We did the E2333000 series.
And we did the E235 series.
What is... Oh, this is I think the... You can build your own.
Let's go to puzzle.
So is it just a puzzle?
I can do... Futsu?
These are so cute.
It looks like a little model.
Actually, it's so cute with the little snippers and everything.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, let's try it.
Futsu... Futsu... Futsu... Normal... Normal...
There's so many.
Oh my gosh.
It's train Gunpla.
Wait, I'm gonna not use my controller for this.
No way.
The base of the model is shown at the top of the screen.
And the parts for the model are shown at the bottom.
Use the R L button to rotate.
Okay, maybe I do need to use my controller.
To rotate the base in 90 degree increments to find the correct angle and position, place the parts.
Select the part and move it to the spot where you think it fits.
On the left side of the screen, you will find a number of features that will come in handy while assembling models.
There is no limit to how many times they can be used, so try them out as much as you like.
So nice.
Masashi.
There's also a 2D model stage and a timer, so keep challenging yourself to achieve the fastest time possible.
Okay, so we're making this.
Why did it feel like it got louder?
This music is like so...
Okay, hold on.
So now I take you...
And I rotate it.
How?
Oh, I can do like that.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
So I rotate the full thing.
And then that was on the other side I saw.
Right here.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, zoom mode.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
We're making it.
Oh, that's so helpful.
I'm guessing...
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Sorry.
There we go.
Okay, confirm.
Well, it kind of like cheats, no?
It tells you where to place it.
It kind of tells you where to place it.
And then this, I imagine, goes there.
And then this on top.
Friendship ended with Gunpla, now Denpla is my new best friend.
I wonder how the hard one is then.
Like, do you... Does it not give you any hints?
Let's try.
We've already done this one, so we're in X.
It's even more... And look at that, it even tells you what part...
What each thing is.
So we're ma... Oh, wow, okay.
Oh, it still does kind of tell you though.
Like, if I just wander around enough...
Will it show me?
Maybe not.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, it's on the front there.
Oh, because you need to like rotate it.
So it's like not so obvious sometimes.
Aha!
Okay, okay, okay.
So this is like the thing we made earlier.
Well, I guess... Okay, hold on.
Well, this was like in the middle, no?
Place?
Place it?
Places?
Congrats
on the new DK!
You can overtake all the other trains and win the train race.
Yippee!
See?
Oh, why would it want this first?
That's so interesting.
And then we know.
We know, we know.
Oh, we even have to assemble the...
The inside.
Aha.
So these are the...
Those are the doorway.
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, at the very end.
Okay.
Haha!
And then this is exactly... Wait, this is exactly as it was before.
But it's not letting me move for some reason.
Oh, there we go.
I wonder
what the difference is between those.
Hard mode.
Look how many pieces there are.
And then you... I'm sorry, how big is this?
Wow!
No way!
It looks so nice.
I would love a model like this.
Like, not to like rag on the... Just the train models themselves, but like an actual...
You know, setting and everything like this would be so nice.
Like, yeah, like a whole diorama, exactly.
Where is Shirokane-Sando Bridge?
Shirokane-Sando Bashi, doko?
Shirokane-Sando Bridge.
It did say that maybe some locations are different due to privacy, but...
I think they wouldn't name it if it weren't...
It's in Shinagawa!
I'm gonna go!
How'd that one bookcase one go?
Oh, it's good!
I didn't finish it.
I did end up finishing it.
It's just hard to take a picture because it's kind of reflective.
I like trains.
I love... Actually, there's... Oh, wait.
I don't know if this...
I don't think it was trains now that I think about it.
It might have been cars.
There's a, like, little toy shop in Haneda Airport where you can race cars.
I don't think it was trains.
But there's also an airplane.
And it's not just, like, an airplane store.
It's, like, a fighter jet store in the Haneda Airport.
And it's... I don't know if it's run by the guy with the YouTube channel, but it's run by, like, an ex...
He was, like, part of... Oh, gosh.
Sorry, my brain is so...
But I saw him!
I saw him last time I was at the airport.
I was like, oh my gosh, that's the guy!
It's upstairs and to the left, right?
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes.
You're right, Todd.
It is, it is, it is.
Yeah.
So it's really cool, actually.
They sell, like, you know, actual...
Which one is it?
What is it?
Haneda... Where's your store list?
And it's not like... It's not like, you know, like...
Passenger planes or commercial planes or anything like that.
It's like... It's like...
Like jets and, you know... It's fun.
I like to go in there and peruse.
I'll find it.
Do they still have that udon place?
I'm pretty sure they still have an udon place in there.
Lots and lots of jets and planes.
And one of my favorite things about Haneda is the observatory deck that they have.
I'm crying.
Not the train guy for you.
Today, I'm here.
Wait, that's... That's not the guy.
I'm like... I'm like fusing the train guy, Francis, and...
What's his name?
Tom Scott.
Did you manage to fix your stream deck?
Yeah, I think it actually... It didn't do it today, so it's actually good.
He does look like Tom Scott, though.
And they're both British.
Osaka airport as a Kamen Rider-ish mascot?
Wait, I wanna see this.
I'm gonna look it up.
Hold on.
Osaka airport mascot.
Wait a second.
I don't think...
I think... Is he new?
Because this one is so...
This guy is so cute.
Wait a second.
How old is this?
Oh my gosh, he's so... Look at this guy!
Hold on.
This is like a... It looks like a Twitter post, but I'm just gonna show you guys anyway.
Because this is... The picture of him is so stinking cute.
Look at him!
He's Sorayan.
Sorayan is his name.
He's so cute.
Not that one.
I didn't think so.
But he's so cute.
Look at his little...
He's so cute.
Where is the Kamen Rider one?
It's not this guy, is it?
Is it this guy?
Miyaku Miyaku!
Is it Miyaku Miyaku?
Osaka's mascot with rolling eyeballs and sunflower-like head?
It's Miyaku Miyaku.
I can't find it.
Did they retire him?
I feel like there would be some pictures of him though.
If you know his name...
Dosei.
The Osaka Kamen Rider... Osaka Airport Kamen Rider mascot.
Rapid... Till Dyer.
That?
Oh my gosh!
The Japanese... Oh, it says spawn from a train.
Sorry, I'm saving things.
And I was like, do you want to re-save?
Look at that!
I was born to protect the peace of Osaka!
That's awesome!
Oh my god!
What train is he?
Okay...
Oh!
Wait, you can see it!
Oh, I mean it's behind him, but like...
You can see it much better in this picture.
It looks so much like him!
Like, actually!
It looks so good!
Retro... Oh no, that's surprise.
What is this?
Okay.
Ranger-esque superhero modeled after the Rapid train line in Osaka...
Which runs between the Kansai International Airport and Namba Station.
Oh, Rapid...
Comes from the German word for rapid.
They made the train look like Squidward.
The resemblance is truly uncanny.
That's so good!
That's so good.
I wonder what Easy is then.
Oh, there's not even that many things we could build.
Let's try this one.
I want to see what this one is like, building on Easy.
Oh.
Wait, this is too easy.
Wait a second!
What do you think I am?
Am I a joke to you?
Actually, how do I get it in there?
Oh, there it is.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is like the best...
Wait, frame me from here instead.
Wait, I want to see the front.
Wait, what is this?
How cute.
I want this diorama.
Oh my gosh, next time I go to Japan, I'm coming here.
I'm going to come here.
Wait.
Hold on, hold on.
Revert!
Tease!
Wait.
I'm going to try to recreate this picture.
You must be a conductor, the way you pilot my heart.
Oh, I have a... hold on.
I have a conductor hat.
All aboard!
Okay, if you guys ever go to... what was this bridge called?
I don't remember.
Hold on, I have it.
Shirokane Sando Bashi.
The Shirokane Sando Bridge.
You must stand here with your minto to go plushie.
And you must take a picture.
Or if I ever have an acrylic stand or something.
Look at me.
I'm the conductor now.
You must recreate this photo, okay?
Here, I'll even write it on the screen for you.
Shirokane Sando Bridge.
Wait, why'd it get so small?
One hand?
Please hold.
Here.
There, there, there.
I shall bring a full-size cardboard minto standee.
Crazy.
Did someone say sandwich?
Yeah, the Shirokane Sandwich Bridge.
Actually, there was a kanji, but I didn't see what the kanji was.
Hold on, maybe we can see it.
Hold on.
It was over here, no?
Shirokane...
Oh gosh.
It just says something.
I can't read the middle one.
Something way bridge.
Sando.
White gold.
Kane as in money?
Yep, yep.
This is such a nice photo.
Wait, I want to kind of like...
This is so like...
Oh, just my...
Oh, it's like...
I want kind of with like the everyday-isms too, you know?
Like the signs and all that.
Get everything in there.
So scenic.
So scenic!
And then this one.
Oh no!
I followed the wrong road!
Can't believe I get to watch Mito build the train.
That goes to Gotanda.
The doors on the right side will open.
Please change here for...
The Keihin-Tohoku line, the Ginza line and the... Wait, she says Keihin-Tohoku last, no?
I'm pulling the lever.
Stop the train!
She's on that!
She's down there!
Look out behind you!
Alright, there's one last thing I did want to do in this.
Oh wait, that was just one... Oh my gosh, there's other...
Nevermind, hold on.
I want to see what the diagram...
Stop!
It's so nice!
Oh my God!
Wait, what is this supposed to look like?
Oh, I see it now.
It's not supposed to be turned a little bit.
It's like... Are you seeing this?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, that's right.
And then all the rocks and the ocean!
She sees the vision.
It's so nice!
Oh my God!
Sorry, I'm obsessed.
Wait!
Oh my God, hold on.
You're just walking along, living your little...
So...
I
want this diorama!
Oh wow!
You're just walking along, living your little...
Oh wait, we gotta be even smaller.
How tall is it?
Wow!
Just living your little life.
Well, I'm dead, but you know...
Can't see it from here.
Ooh!
What is... What's the view from up here?
Oh my God, I'm the conductor.
Oh my God!
I should have played this in 3D.
I should have played this with my 3D model.
Wow!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I wish it was a little easier to move around.
Yeah!
Choo-choo!
Cab ride.
Empty.
They're like, can I show you the toilet secrets?
Nice.
How many is it?
Oh, four.
Occupied!
It's so detailed.
Is this like to get in here?
It's so nice!
It's so stinking nice.
A ghost train.
Oh my God!
Wow!
Wait, hold on.
I can see why people get into model train sets.
From the park.
You can probably see it from the top.
Ah!
Just barely.
Oh!
Oh my God.
Yeah!
Oh, that's the base of the diagram.
Diorama.
Not diagram, sorry.
My brain is really slow today.
Yes!
Wait.
Can we see it from the sea?
No, not enough.
Not enough.
The tide must really come up here.
I don't know.
Oh my gosh!
This is so... This is so nice!
OK, let's go to the other one too.
Let's go to the other one too.
You.
I'm sorry, I keep doing the easy ones because I like the... I like putting them together too, but the diagram is just...
Sorry, diorama.
It's just so nice.
It's just... I like...
It's so... It's so funny.
There we go.
I love diagrammas.
Look at this.
Beauty.
Oh my gosh, and there's so many.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's so long.
Is there a... Hold on.
There's no like...
I wish it had one of the cross... The train crosses, you know.
I'm trying to find a good...
Maybe like...
Oh my gosh!
All aboard the Phantom Train!
Next stop, Akihabara Station!
And then... Oh my gosh, wait.
We can go in here?
We can go in... And pretend we're looking out the window.
Wait, hold on.
We need the actual seat.
Like this one.
No, this view is better.
Over here.
Yeah!
Oh, blue train seat's comfy.
Okay.
Now...
It's time...
For the layout.
Guys...
Which one?
We gotta build our own railway.
We got an elevated railway.
Seaside with mount.
Oh, that one sounds really nice.
As someone who works at a train museum, I can confirm trains are cool.
That's so cool!
Number three, seaside.
Okay, we'll go with seaside.
Pre-created layout.
I wonder how detailed we can get in here.
What is auto?
Oh, none of the trains go in.
Edit!
When editing your layout, you can freely arrange and edit railway vehicles and structures.
Diorama parts.
Vehicles.
Place railway vehicles on your choice within your scene.
Start by choosing the lead train car you wish to place then if there are any center cars.
Oh my gosh, we can make the longest train ever.
Congrats on 350k!
Thank you!
Last year has been so much better because you were here.
Today is my birthday!
Can I possibly get some birthday magic from my Kamehame... Mr. M?
Of course!
Happy Birthday!
Moe moe!
Birthday!
Magic!
Obliterated.
No!
Happy Birthday!
I'm sad I couldn't watch more of this stream due to work.
No, guys!
Have a good day with work.
You can only form a train that consists of cars in the same series.
Choose the structures you wish to use and place them in your scene.
Environment.
You can change the time of day to midday, evening or night.
Oh my god.
Wait, what kind of... People!
Oh my gosh, the train otaku are out.
Wait, there is so much here!
Oh my god.
I can put other vehicles too!
And dogs and cats!
Wait, wait, wait...
Why does he look like he is pooping there?
Shiba Inu lying down.
There is a big old field of them.
Oh no!
Wrong one.
What's the cats?
They are so... This looks demonic a little bit.
Oh!
Plants, lard...
Oh my goodness!
Holy cow!
Wait, this is perfect for a...
You know?
For a scene.
I wish... Hold on.
I'm gonna see if I can find a way to turn down here.
Hold on.
I'm pretty sure there is a way.
Sound effects.
There we go.
Oh, it's now too small.
Volume large.
Okay, perfect.
We are editing.
What's long distance?
Oh!
Congrats on 30,000 subs!
Here is some more big subscriber milestone.
Thank you, Sakura!
Yes, this game is on Steam.
This game is on Steam.
That's where I got it.
Someone in pre-chat was just like...
Mint, how did you find this game?
It has 6 reviews.
Because I'm just looking up train games.
Wow!
I wanna make like a really pretty place, but I'm not good at that.
Oh, wait.
Circle 7?
Wait, what's this one?
Gmart.
Wait, these are so... Oh, it kind of... I guess it's...
This one has like the colors of 7-Eleven, but...
How do I rotate it?
Oh, here we go.
Like that.
But circle... Oh, no, that's circle T.
Just kidding.
I thought it was circle 7.
Got little buildings.
More buildings.
Constructing buildings.
Traditional buildings.
Wow, this is so cool!
Wow!
Oh my gosh, there's so much!
Hatsune Mike!
Thank you so much!
7-Eleven plus FamiMart.
Yeah, yeah.
Jevin.
Jevin Eleven.
These containers, I wanna fold them.
Okay, so let's do our car.
Which one should we do?
I like the 185 series.
So let's put... Oh, you?
Down?
Whoa, whoa!
Wait, did I...
Oh, cool!
Okay, hold on.
We'll do... We'll do the solo.
We'll do like Moha solo.
Any graveyards?
I wish, right?
Where'd it go?
Hello?
Oh, it's a... Oh!
Do you see it going?
Whoa, the sky turned red!
Oh, this is kind of freaky.
Oh my god, what kind of evening is this?
This is the evening before everybody dies?
This is an... This is like...
Yeah, we're in terrain hell.
This is the graveyard someone requested, yeah.
Going through the tunnel!
I wonder if they sound different, the trains.
Evangelion moment reel.
Oh, they're about to pass by the bugs!
And the dogs!
So pretty!
This game is awesome.
Are we able to ride the train?
I'm trying to figure that out.
Wait, I want to go to...
I don't want to be...
Oh, we can watch it like this too!
I don't want to be the conductor though.
I want to be like, sitting on the train and all.
What's photographer?
Oh, not a single cameraman has been assigned.
Oh, my bad.
Okay.
Long distance.
Okay, this is us just moving.
And this is our photography.
And then we can be inside.
Nah, I want to be the Passover princess.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh, wait!
There's the bugs!
And they're... Hold on, we're gonna pass all the dogs.
There they are!
Hold on, let's... Oh, whoops, my bad.
Let's do...
Maybe if we...
Condorctor.
I want to make like a really good place though.
I just... Oh my gosh.
What we can also do is, because I'm stupid with this kind of stuff, is...
We can go to the pre-made place too.
Wait, oh, wait.
No, no, no.
You move here.
Jump?
Oh my gosh, I'm controlling the photographer!
Look at all these dogs.
This is like a cursed site.
The dog's lying in it.
More dogs!
I've possessed the camera lady!
And you know what they say about cherry blossom trees, right?
That there's dead bodies buried underneath... Or dead body underneath it.
Look at that star, so bright.
Oh, shot, shoot!
I missed the shot.
What?
Yeah, that's true!
Wait, what?
Look it up.
Look it up, look it up.
This is so funny.
Oh my goodness, this game is awesome.
This game is so awesome!
Streams like this make me happy, me too!
Grab the shovel, let's find out.
Look, the ocean.
We can see the train.
Oh wow, oh my gosh!
OK,
let's make some more stuff.
Can the camera man go for a swim?
You just want her to have a wet T-shirt, you perv.
I don't know if she's wearing a white T-shirt though.
Can she fall off the map?
That's a better question.
Oh, here we go!
She made it!
Shot!
Dead bodies beneath the sakura, spawning zombie dog legions.
Totally how it goes.
This game is so fun!
I don't know, could you even call this a game?
It's a game.
It's like a sandbox, no?
This is good, this is good.
Yeah, for sure.
I like this thing.
This is their god.
And then this is Solid Snake.
What else can we make?
Gosh, there's so many things.
Let's make some more buildings.
Like this guy.
Many windowed house.
Wow, perfect for peeping in.
Chinese stone bridge?
I don't think so.
Maritetsu cafeteria, yeah.
Too many windows.
Iguchi office.
We'll put that over here.
There's so many...
Yeah, we need, I think, a building.
A large building for...
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
Oh god!
I think there's a bit of a...
You know, a pretty big gap between medium building and large building.
Hello, baby girl.
It's Pies.
Come here, Pies.
You want out?
I can't let my cat out.
My kitten.
My little kitten.
Let's see, where can we put the vibrant brick apartment building?
It's so big.
What if we put it at the top of the mountain?
Wow, it works!
Oh, what?
High rise.
Wow!
A very scenic view of a giant apartment on a mountain.
Japan is living in 2077.
With these architectural feats.
Guys, I'm sorry if I sneeze.
I feel one coming.
Unlabeled gas tank.
That does not make me feel very good.
We'll put that in the ocean.
This is what will spawn Godzilla.
What is this?
Oh, it's a watchtower.
Interesting.
Put this on top of the mountain too.
Can I ride the watchtower?
Of course.
Bless you in advance.
This pollen...
Is making me sneeze.
Okay, hold on.
We're gonna go back.
We're gonna go back because there is a pre-made place.
And it probably looks much nicer than...
Than what I've done.
Look at that.
It's so boring though, no?
It's just a little loop.
There's no...
There's no depth or anything.
We're zooming.
Was that a dog?
I hope nobody was trying to crash because...
There's no like...
No nothing to stop you.
Those were people!
Oh!
Oh, it's a photographer!
And a dog trying to poop in the front of the conbini.
Another photog... Oh, I hope he got a good shot.
Wait, which photographer am I?
Oh, this looks so nice.
Wait, this looks amazing!
And there's a cat!
Oops.
I want it with... Wait, what did I just do?
Hey, what's happening?
That looks so good!
You can teleport between tracks.
I see!
They physically won't let you get run over by the train.
I see.
They will not allow you to get run over by the train.
They actually refuse.
That's a good one.
That's a good one!
I came back to Conductor Minto, bless.
Yeah, they're just like, no siree!
Here it comes, here it comes, here it comes.
Oh,
yeah!
I'm getting some really great shots!
Is there any other photographers?
Look how cute the city is!
Why am I huge?
Wait, I think I'm a giant.
Professional photographer.
I want some pictures from over here too.
Game center!
Maybe from this side.
Oh my gosh!
The train on that side!
Go pass it through!
Looks so good.
I'm a bit of a giantess.
Is anyone into that?
A train haiku.
A dog tries to poop in front of the konbini.
Mint Phantom likes trains.
No comment.
Cute!
So cute.
I love this game.
I'm gonna try and build something really nice one day.
I wanna build something really nice.
So cozy core, right?
Here it comes.
I like the front of it.
I like the front of the trains.
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
I need to get to Osaka.
Where is my train?
It would rather me be impaled by a tree...
Than be impaled by the train.
JR is like, we will not have your blood on our hands.
Even if it's just a video game.
Wait, I want one from...
No, I want one from up here.
Because this is, you know, this is all official stuff.
It's like an official...
Will they ever come to my stop?
Are they ever gonna stop for me?
So this is like official, which is really cool, I think.
Get one from the platform.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I want one.
Wait, hold on.
There we go, this is good.
It's a little close, but...
Ah!
Happens if you jump in front of it.
Let's try.
Out of rice, please.
We got teleported.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, no, no, no, I didn't mean to press back!
Please!
No!
This town is pretty empty, though.
There is just the one person.
I gotta go take some allergy medicine, I think.
And the dog.
Wait, run to the playground, it might be so good.
Photographer!
Run to the playground.
Oh.
It's like I'm part-time worker town.
Yeah.
I have to buy tickets for my next Japan trip.
But they are so expensive!
Cats!
Okay, from here might be good.
Nice.
I'm part-time worker!
Dude...
It's like Pies and Butaro hanging out.
What is this goofy-ass smile?
Oh, God.
He is the devil.
At least this guy has like some life in his eyes.
This guy... Oh my gosh, you can see his toe-beats!
So freaky.
Yeah, he's got a little mustache.
It's so cute.
Hold on, one from on top of the slide.
Oh, I keep pressing back.
No!
Well guys, I might actually end it here.
This is very cozy-comfy.
Very silly-goofy.
Very train.
I learned a lot actually though.
So thank you for everybody, all the real train otaku coming in and teaching me.
I learned so much.
Very train.
We learned so much.
I don't imagine I will stream this game again.
But if I ever wanted something, maybe like a members building an actual town kind of thing would be fun.
Chug-a-choo!
Not a Japan train otaku, but still enjoyed it.
Are you an other place train otaku?
Because I know some people are like...
Electric trains, not my style.
Give me them locomotive.
Give me those...
Chugging-chugging ones, you know.
Mint-o-veal.
From Singapore.
I see, I see.
I'm not really into trains.
But it's always fun to watch Mint-o excited about something.
Thank you!
Cole enjoyers here.
Perhaps you would indeed enjoy Densha de GO!
I do really want to play Densha de GO!
So...
It has been on my list for quite a long time.
Steam engines are romantic, electric are effective.
That is such a good way to put it.
Yes!
I understand completely!
I think that's like the perfect way to say it.
Yeah, like the steam is romantic, it's aesthetic.
And then electric is like...
All efficiency, baby.
I have seen some like...
Some...
Train...
Not really tours, but like...
I've seen some through like mountains and stuff.
I think there was one like in California or Colorado that I watched recently.
That I was like, I wanna ride it!
I wanna go.
I visited the Kyoto Railway Museum at the end of my trip last month.
It was a lot of fun seeing the steam locomotives up close.
There was one I went to in Nagoya before.
I can't remember the name of it, but I went to that train museum.
Colorado has a steam train, yeah.
I prefer electric for the daily commute for sure.
But anything that's like kind of like...
I don't know.
Like you said...
Even if they could like, you know, in the future, if they stopped...
Like the steam...
Trains entirely.
If they could like recreate it with just like the aesthetic.
I think that would still be nice too.
Rocky Mountaineer is a beautiful trip.
Have you ever ridden the metro in DC?
I have!
I have actually.
Yeah, so...
Like trains vaping.
Don't say it like that!
It's cursed.
It's too cursed.
Anyway,
this was so fun!
Thank you guys.
I did mention it was gonna be a bit of a shorter stream.
But if you wanna hang out some more later...
I will be on Doki Bird's channel...
In a couple of hours.
So she will be playing Visage and I will be...
Helping her out.
And I think she might be...
Drunk?
Tipsy?
I don't know.
I'm scared.
Thanks for the super chill and educational stream!
Thanks to Argo!
Thank you!
Former railroad employee here.
We always call them railroad sexuals.
Or train sexuals.
Guys who take pictures of everything to rebuild it at home.
I mean...
But also we can just get like a nice train photo.
It's so aesthetic, no?
I think.
Same with like planes.
I like to go to the...
Haneda Airport Observatory and...
Look at the planes taken off and try to get good pictures.
There's always people there with like big old cameras.
So fun.
I don't know the...
I think I prefer planes over trains.
But in terms of photography...
I prefer train photography over plane photography.
Because with train photography...
You can, I feel...
Get more variety.
But with planes it's like...
Oh, it's up in the sky again.
But in terms of like...
Tech and...
Interest, I think planes take over trains for me.
Sorry, every train otaku here.
It's also hard to get close to planes.
What if a train was up in the sky?
I think we'd have some...
Some big problems.
Actually, this is so funny.
Well, I wonder if I could say this.
The last time I met Kiara in Japan...
She wanted to do a little bit of a photo shoot.
And so I have like...
A ton of photos of her at a train station.
And I'm like...
First of all, it's Kiara.
She's so stinking cute.
And then it's Kiara at the train station.
So I'm just like...
It's like my treasures, my treasures.
She's so cute.
That's all in my phone.
They look like stalker shots a little bit.
But that's okay.
Printed all over your wall like Bocchi.
So true.
I could just stare up at the ceiling.
Anyway...
Thank you guys for today.
We shall do more train things in the future.
I want to become train educated.
I will wear this hat with pride.
And it will be...
It will be...
Something I earned.
And also...
Thank you!
Otsumito!
Thanks for watching!
Thanks for hanging out!
Remember that maritime vessel?
Get out of here!
Better than both planes and trains?
Flying train.
Astro train from Transformers.
Otsumito!
Thank you guys!
Train collab with the train operator.
That would be fun!
Bye bye!
Otsumito!
Thank you!
Bye bye!